All right. Hi, everybody. This is Michelle with Conor's Clinic and I'm having the great opportunity
to interview a patient of ours. She's been with us for going on two years now. Her name is
Christina Kranz. Hi, Christina. Hello. Thank you so much for being here with us. I'd love for you
to start out by giving us just a small introduction on who you are, kind of what was your diagnosis
when you started with us, and anything else that you'd like to do just to kind of profess who you
are to potential patients and current patients who are watching this. Well, thank you for having
me today. It was really honored to be asked and it's been a journey. So let me just introduce who I am
and then I'd love to share a little bit about where I am right now. I'm a 35 year old single woman.
I'm a nurse midwife and have worked in hospital settings and home settings. Alternative care has
been part of my background, um, car practice, acupuncture, those kinds of things. I was diagnosed with
endometrial cancer in January of 2018 and kind of shocked by it because I lived a really healthy
lifestyle and just thought I'm the health care provider. I'm not a patient. So I live in
Western New York State, grew up with a big family and on a farm. I live the outdoors. I love being
creative, making pottery. And I love caring for people and I love the Lord Jesus Christ. So
that's kind of who I am and cancer has rocked my world, stretched me, grown me, made me a different
person, a different provider, much more compassionate to people who are suffering and I've seen my god
in a completely different way. He's been me the whole way. So that's a bit of who I am.
That's perfect. So being that you've had a history of being alternatively minded,
what was it like for you to receive that diagnosis given that most people in the alternative spectrum
they're wanting to be healthy because they don't want cancer to come in the future but often most of
them haven't considered the what if. What would I do if? And so when you get that diagnosis,
you can be faced with some pretty big decisions and some emotional sways because there's so much fear
that surrounds it. So I'm curious to know what was it like for you to make those decisions moving
forward after you were diagnosed? I had watched two of my grandparents through treatments for cancer
and I had also had a couple of friends who had done alternative treatments for cancer. So I'd
kind of seen both firsthand. Yes, I was shocked that I had cancer and you know, my first thought was,
oh my goodness, I'm going to go through treatments. I'm going to lose all my hair and then I kind of
paused, you know, and thought, oh wait a second. Right, I could do something different. And I think part
of the process was trying to decide if the people around me were supportive. So I found my family
very, very supportive and I think that helped me a lot in making the big decisions of how to use
conventional treatments in a supportive way but really focusing on alternative treatments.
So I guess I really had to ask myself, did I really believe that alternative treatments
were as good as I'd always thought for the big, the big one for cancer? So yes, I was prepared to
embrace it but I had a lot of questions in the process. Yeah, as you began to move forward, how was it
blending your primary use of alternative medicine or your desire to use that with maintaining a
relationship with a traditional doctor or an oncological team? It's been a little touch-and-go
but I have to say I have had some wonderful doctors in conventional oncology. Sometimes I've left
the office feeling a lot of doubt. They've instilled that doubt in me and all of their questions.
Other visits, they've been very affirming. One doctor said to me, I'm the vice president, you're the
president and the next time he's like, well, so here's my plan. I'm hoping you're going to go along with it.
So I usually just maintain that I don't make big decisions in the office and I think that they've come
to respect that. So for myself, I also just purport myself. I am a health care professional. I was
trained in nursing so I have a language to share with them and then I usually just say, but I appreciate
science and some science is showing me that conventional therapy isn't enough. And so I usually just
sound really confident in the office and then I leave and I say to my mom, oh my goodness, I have to
like offload the things that they've said to me otherwise they keep rolling around in my mind.
Well, this could blow up someday. Do you feel comfortable in giving an example of that,
kind of the difficulty that you've had to traverse? You certainly don't have to name names. I want to
protect and honor that relationship that you have with those practitioners. And so I want to make
sure that we're keeping everything above board. But can you give an example because I'm sure that you
wouldn't be alone in this? Sure. So you mean an example of something that was said that I've had
to disagree with? Either that or a tough conversation where in the office you were really having to weigh out
what it is that you believe in your heart with just navigating that conversation with somebody who's
claiming or is believed to be an expert within that field? Sure. I would say there was a time when I
was declining to do MRIs every three months, which is what their request was. And I instead had
decided to use the IVG test with Dr. Connors and ultrasound because it didn't include the
gallenium dye. And the NP who saw me during this particular visit basically came in the room with an
agenda and she told me you need an MRI. You really should do a histroscopy and a biopsy and she told
this to me like three times. She didn't even ask me, did I have questions that day? I was really taking
a back and kind of felt bullied. And then she was getting ready to leave the room and said, well if you
have any questions you know you can always call. And I just all of a sudden realized that I needed to
like speak up and stop her and so I said, well actually I do have some things to say. And I was
able to just communicate a couple things that you know communicated that I was thoughtful, that I was
thinking about this, that I wasn't wearing rosy-colored glasses and saying don't worry I'm just going
to get well. I know I'm going to get well. I basically had to reframe that I'm a thoughtful conscientious
person and the things I chose were different than hers but I was still watching what was going on and
making my decisions based on what my values were. And she didn't really give a lot of honor and
affirmation to that but I had to say it and I think that it helped her to maybe just realize that I
was choosing something different and not being neglectful.
Yeah that's great. It wasn't really a lot of resolve but you know I had to speak up because otherwise
she was going in the room saying Christina's just saying no to everything I'm offering and instead I
had to reframe it and say I'm actually saying yes to things you're not offering. Right I think
that's good and that's clearing whether or not your conversation ultimately changed her as a human
being moving forward maybe even the biggest part of that conversation was for you in that you
needing to say something with love and grace that was trying to bridge that gap or to connect
the two sides together was allowing you to walk away feeling like you're doing everything that you
can to maintain that healthy relationship. Sure I think that's true. Yeah. How has traditional medicine
been helpful for you? I have utilized a progesterone therapy which is a prescription medication
that has been the main conventional treatment I have used and then imaging so I maintain a working
relationship with my oncologist for those two services primarily. Okay. Being that you chose you
did your research and chose to come to work with Connors Clinic. How did Connors Clinic provide you
the elements that you were looking for within the alternative spectrum? I know that you are
well researched and that you really took your time to make this decision prayerfully and academically
and so how did how did we as a clinic come alongside you the way that you felt you needed?
I felt like Connors Clinic has always treated me like a person and a person with knowledge and opinions
and a spirit and emotions and a physical body and a relational body and few other providers
offer that kind of care so I have felt like Connors Clinic has honored me as a whole being.
I also feel like the education and the community be it the Zoom calls or the Facebook group
or just being able to go to the website and look up like modified citrus pectin. What's it for?
Why do I take it? How do I take it? There are just so many resources even on the webpage and
I don't know you've all been wonderfully encouraging in the process even if my news has been hard news.
You've just kind of sat with me during that and then given me hope like okay let's do another
distance kinesiology and see what the next answer is and to me that just offers up a lot of hope
because there's always something else to explore and find that's going on in my body that might give
a clue as to why things are going well or why things are going poorly. So I feel like it's been
multi-level kind of care that I've received from Connors Clinic. Well I'm glad to hear that.
Well last question in this segment if there was something or some things you can have them be plural
to messages that you would like to provide for current patients that we have or potential patients
something that's been on your heart that you'd want to share I want to give you the opportunity
to dispense that information and you know maybe provide some people are looking for encouragement or
just a different way to look at things just some of that guidance and wisdom that I know that you've
gained over the years that you've been working with us. Sure I would say the first thing is that when
I was first diagnosed I realized the culture of fear that surrounds oncology and I felt that from
my oncologist I felt it from the radiologist stirring imaging and it's like hurry up and make decisions
fast or you don't even have time to make decisions here's the plan sign on the dotted line and I
I guess the Lord just gave me that perception right away that there's a lot of fear-based decision-making
and there's just this little truth in the Bible that says that perfect love casts out fear and I
realized that fear shouldn't be making any of my decisions for me because love should cast out
fear and then I should be able to make decisions in wisdom. So I have just I guess gained the awareness
that making a decision out of fear is usually going to be heard and regretted later I don't make
decisions in the office if I get new imaging results and they give me a plan I usually just say okay
I'll give it some thought and I'll get back to you so my encouragement to anybody who is in the decision
making process which is kind of continuously but particularly if you're first diagnosed or trying to
decide even on alternative care to to just pause and to identify fears and to let the Holy Spirit
rid those fears instead be surrounded by God's love that casts out fears and then make sound decisions
that would be my first encouragement and it's really really easy to get sucked into make this decision now
but just kind of have these antennas up like fear is not a great place to be making decisions
and the second thing I'd say is to ask for wisdom and after I spoke with Dr. Connors the first time
ever I did my interview with him and he just gave me this wonderful piece of advice that I have done
over and over and over and it is ask God for wisdom about what direction to take because
he's going to give you the answer he says ask for wisdom and I will give it to you liberally and
without scolding you that's in James and over and over I ask for wisdom I ask for wisdom before I
go to appointments I ask for wisdom before I call Connors Clinic and say hey can you do distance
kinesiology for me I ask for wisdom sometimes about fixing my food is this a good thing for me to
be eating today or have I eaten this too many days in a row maybe I need to switch things up
I just ask for wisdom about the littlest things now because I understand he really wants me to come
asking for wisdom so whether you're making decisions that are a little or big
ask he doesn't ever scold us for asking and he wants to give it to us liberally
and the third thing I would say is I would never have guessed it actually we think well for the
last two years but I am thank you that's wonderful well Christina thank you so much for answering
these questions for me and for all of us who will be watching in the future what a blessing
you have been blessing as a patient to our clinic and we're looking forward to many years ahead
so thank you for talking with us today you're welcome it's been my pleasure